>> Good evening, please welcome
Shari
Werb director of Center for
learning, literacy and
engagement
[Applause]
>> Hello, I'm delighted to
welcome youto
Tracy K Smith closing up in as
our 22nd poet laureate
consultant in poetry.
Tracy was the first laureate
appointed by our current
librarian of Congress, Carla
Hayden.
And in September 2017 the
librarians stood on this stage
and welcomed her to the
position.
My introduction to Tracy came
last fall when I began as
director of the library's new
Center for learning, literacy
and engagement.
Just a few weeks into the job, I
found myself traveling to the
Black Hills of South Dakota to
join one of our
laureates seven American
conversation project trips
around the country along with
Rob Casper, director of the
poetry
Center and Guy Lemelin are
olinara with the Center for the
book, we visited the guy foolish
center and Opera center in
Spearfish and the Sturgis public
library.
In each place, Tracy read poems
from her anthology, American
Journal, 50 poems for our time.
And asked a simple question.
What did you notice?
Through that unassuming yet
powerful question and with
humility, warmth and
an openness to whatever
responses she
received, Tracy helped audiences
connect to one another through
poetry.
American conversations as well
as the
slowdown, Tracy's additional
laureate project of weekday
podcasts and
broadcasts have proven the
poetry can help us, whoever we
are in our day-to-day lives.
By sharing in the safe space
that Tracy, her poems and
laureate projects create, we are
encouraged to reflect, discuss
and empathize.
To deepen our connection to our
community, and even be part of a
new community.
This does more than prove the
power of the art. It helps
strengthen civic society.
Tracy has shown me the
transformative
power of this work and has given
me a sense of what the Library
of Congress should aim for.
Just as I am thankful she
brought me to South Dakota, I'm
thankful she has
chosen to share the stage night
with poets laureate representing
Hawaii, Indiana, Clark County
Nevada, Brooklyn New York and
Oklahoma. All of whom have done
their own amazing work.
Tracy will begin the event with
an
address, then welcome her fellow
poets laureate on stage.
Joining them will be Jennifer
Benka, president and executive
director of the Academy of
American poets, who will lead a
moderated discussion.
I want to note that in just nine
days, for the first time, the
Academy of American poets will
award over $1
million to 10 to 20 poets
serving as
laureates of states, cities,
counties,
US territories or tribal nations
to recognize literary excellence
and fuel civic projects. Please
join me in congratulating
Jennifer and the Academy.
[Applause]
>> Before I turn the microphone
over to
Tracy, I want to take a moment
to acknowledge our dear poet
laureate as one of our country's
national treasures.
At many American conversation
events,
Tracy began by reading from her
most recent collection, Wade in
the water.
The found poem sequence, I will
tell you the truth about this, I
will tell
you all about it featuring
letters from African-American
soldiers petitioning the
government for
their pensions often elicited
audible responses from the
audience.
Tracy called the experts from
to Burks, families and freedom,
a documentary history of
African-American
kinship in the Civil War era
drawn from the Friedman and
Southern Society
project at the University of
Maryland, and voices of
emancipation,
understanding slavery, the Civil
War and Reconstruction through
the US pension Bureau files.
I can think of no better example
of promoting civic literacy and
giving
voice to a past often ignored or
forgotten while showcasing the
importance of research and
primary source documents. And I
will tell you the truth about
this.
I will tell you all about it,
Tracy models how such documents
can inspire each of us.
How we too can engage with the
library, reach in and explore
its wealth of collections and
find our connection to the past.
In the title poem from Wade in
the water, Tracy connects the
past to her own story.
The poem begins, one of the
women greeted me. I love you,
she said. She didn't know me,
but I believed her.
And a terrible new ache rolled
over my chest like a room where
the drapes have been swept back.
There's so much to unpack in
these opening lines that shows
us poetry's
power, to situate us in the
world as
well as within our fears and
desires, to capture the
complexity of an overwhelming
moment through simile.
And to plainly and powerfully
act with love and grace.
When Tracy read this poem during
her American conversation
events, she would also describe
the process of writing it.
The poem is dedicated to the
Guiche
Golla ring showers as you return
to the greeting as a kind of
rumination while
describing their performance and
layering it in image after image
with history.
When she could no longer
describe, Tracy's mind and
imagination leapt. As only those
of poets can. And she arrived at
these last lines.
Oh Woods, a dog, a tree, oh gun,
oh girl, run.
All miraculous mini gone, a
Lord, Lord, Lord, is this the
trouble you promised.
This is the kind of poem we
need.
A poem that gives shape to what
we cannot otherwise say in ways
we can all feel. If we are to
get past our differences and
share our most profound, most
painful and beautiful moments of
living, poems such as Wade in
the water show us a way.
On behalf of the Library of
Congress, I would like to say
thank you, Tracy for serving as
the nation's poet laureate. And
thank you for the opportunity
you
have given me, the library, and
everyone
you have met these last two
years to connect with you
through poetry. Please join me
in welcoming Tracy K Smith.
[Applause]
>> Thank you.
>> Thank you and thank you Sheri
for that wonderful and moving
introduction.
I'd like to begin these remarks
with thanks for Dr.
Carla Hayden, who changed my
relationship both to poetry and
to America.
The profound honor of being
named poet laureate has urged me
to think deeply
and ongoingly about why poetry
matters and to enter into
life-changing encounters with
other Americans from Alaska to
Louisiana. Via poetry.
I would also like to thank the
staff of the poetry and  I would
also like to thank the staff of
the poetry and Literature Ctr.
, Anya Cratyny Rob Holmes and
Casper
for moving quickly and
magnificently to facilitate my
poet laureate project,
American conversations,
celebrating poetry in rural
communities. Can we clap for
them?
[Applause]
>> I had an idea of what I'd
hoped to do.
But I had no idea how such a
thing might happen and they
together with the
guy Lemolinara from the national
Center for the book shepherded
my wish into exhilarating
reality.
I feel indescribably lucky to
have benefited from their
vision, their know-how, their
wisdom and enthusiasm, and if
you know Rob, you know what I
mean by enthusiasm.
[Applause]
>> I also owe a tremendous
thanks to
Jeff shots and Fiona McRae at
Grable's P Gray Wolf press and
much more than thanks to my
wonderful husband Rafael Allison
[Applause]
>> Who kept our home and our
children
both afloat and anchored during
these two years of nonstop
travel. So thank you.
My hope for the American
conversations project was
twofold.
On one hand as a poet who
typically
reads in university communities
and encounters audiences at
literary festivals, I was eager
to venture beyond
campuses and urban centers in my
engagement with poetry and
poetry audiences.
I wanted to travel to places
that
aren't typically targets for a
great deal of literary
programming.
But on the other hand, I was
also very determined to push
back against the pervasive
narrative of America as a
divided nation.
The narrative that says people
in the
rural heartland have nothing in
common, not even a shared
language with those of us in
urban centers.
I harbored the hope that if
anything
could defy this notion of an on
cross of all national divide it
would surely be poetry.
Which jostles us out of our rote
engagement with the world and
opens us
up with humility and curiosity
to other perspectives on
experience.
I believed that poetry fosters a
deepening relationship with
reality, a more conscious and
deliberate engagement with the
lives of others, and with the
inner life that each of us
houses.
I believed that reading poetry
builds in us a reserve of
perspectives and strategies for
living.
I believed that poetry reminds
us to think of life as dynamic
rather than
static, mysterious and rich
rather than flat or Pat.
And the poems open our minds to
the realness and the usefulness
of others experiences.
That they instill in us a sense
of
participation in a long and
ongoing history of human joy,
struggle and hope. That was my
theory.
And what I found in practice on
each of our journeys was
incredibly heartening.
Together with my crew from the
library, we'd land in a new
place, gather our
bearings in a local restaurant,
gate in all at the power and the
particular
beauty of the particular
landscape on what might be a two
or 3 Hour Dr.
and and up in a public library
or community center or some
other venue full of
strangers miraculously willing
to read poems with
me and enter into candid on
Goddard
conversation unguarded
conversation.
Condition by media exposure to
expect a sense of difference or
division I felt
and feel indescribably lucky to
have found my
way to a counter narrative of
thoughtful listening and mutual
respect as fostered by poetry.
Reading poems with others and
talking in ordinary rather than
critical or
analytical language about what
poems cause us to notice,
remember, wonder
and feel, has been a way of
getting to
know one another and accessing
vital feelings in a space of
safety.
Poems have been these amazing
tools for reminding us no matter
who we are of the things we
share. And that's not all.
Poems also highlight the
differences
between us, advocating
implicitly for the validity of
differing perspectives.
I am aware of what we were able
to impart on these trips.
Some people discovered the ways
that poems offer a means of
capturing and examining the
strange and remarkable features
of our lives.
Like a nine-year-old girl in New
Haven Kentucky who came by
herself to a Saturday morning
conversation at her local public
library, which was her home away
from home. She sat by herself in
the front row.
And I could see her taking
everything in carefully.
When finally she raised her
hand, she asked when did you
realize that you had stories to
tell?
I told her I was just about her
age when I tried to write my
first poem. Do you feel like you
have stories to tell I asked
her?
And she told us one that
surprised and worried many of
us.
You can grow up to be a writer
if you want to, I told her. And
after I got home I sent a box of
books to that small branch,
thinking about what might make a
difference to a kid like her.
Others reclaimed a long
neglected level of poetry.
After an event at old Somerton
high school in South Carolina, a
group of women who were members
of the first integrated
graduating class described how
they had
written poetry back when they
were students and how our
conversation had inspired them
to return to the practice.
Others discovered a new sense of
freedom in being able to talk
about poems using the language
they live in everyday.
A man in the audience at a class
I was
invited to give in Wyoming
raised his hand midway through a
conversation about a poem to say
I get it.
When you read a poem you're just
kind of pouring it through your
own filter to see what gets
caught there.
My filter is different from your
filter and different things will
get caught in your filter at
different times depending on who
and where you are when you read
the poem.
Still others, like in a youth
juvenile detention center near
Juneau Alaska sought out poems
on themes deeply relevant to
their lives, but difficult to
broach in everyday conversation.
Themes like suicide, trauma and
addiction.
But I also want to emphasize
what the people in these
communities gave, what the
people in these communities gave
to
us is of equal importance to
what they might have taken away.
American conversations was not
about cityfolk going into
educate rural folk.
It was about the way the poetry
changes
everyone's view of the world and
how it changes our view of
ourselves.
Returning to cities for readings
and
events over these last two years
I have become increasingly aware
of the kinds of unwitting urban
bias present in many of
the questions,
well-meaning questions like so
what is the rural experience
like, or what is rural's
America's reaction to poetry or
did you encounter any resistance
or hostility on these trips.
Questions with thought
affirmation that the many
different rural communities in
this nation are alike.
Characterized by one easily
summarize a
trait and uniformly wary or
suspicious of outsiders.
In fact, I was shocked early
into my
first term
to be asked point-blank, were
you surprised by the
intelligence of people's
responses in rural communities.
If there is indeed a divide in
this
nation perhaps it is perpetuated
by unthinking assumptions like
these.
Assumptions rooted in the wish
to summarize or characterize the
unknown
other as something single,
unified, predictable,
measurable.
I like to believe these kinds of
other
defining questions didn't come
up during
in the actual
American conversations tour
because in every setting
participants were engaging in a
new configuration of momentary
community. I was there with
staff members from DC. People
from neighboring towns were
present, sometimes creating an
unexpected or unlikely
cross-section of community.
Sometimes audience member drove
from
hours away out of an existing
love of poetry or they thought
it was important for their kids
to see someone speaking in an
official capacity, who, as they
often said look like them.
One Kentucky mother said the
exact opposite, that she wanted
to expose her children to the
viewpoint of someone who looked
nothing like them.
The concept of we was different
from gathering to gathering.
Which means there wasn't enough
of a
certainty about who we together
were for participants to seek a
certainty
about who we weren't, or how we
were different from another
specific group or demographic. I
think that's important.
I think placing ourselves in new
configurations of community is
something we ought to seek out
more often.
Because it helps to unsettle the
feelings of confidence and
authority that cause us to
forget how much we can learn
from others who are not like
ourselves.
I will never forget the powerful
uncertainty I felt at a home for
veterans and pioneers about an
hour outside of Anchorage
Alaska., Apart from one or two
members of the audience nobody
volunteered to speak.
I would read a poem and ask a
question, what do you notice,
and it would be followed by a
longer than was comfortable
period of silence.
Sometimes as I was reading, and
audience member would audibly
moan.
It was a reaction I wasn't used
to and it was difficult at times
to sit with the long stretches
of unfilled silence.
But afterward, staff members
were visibly excited.
It turned out that a sizable
portion of the audience was made
up of nonverbal
members of the facility's
Alzheimer's wing.
Those moans and the inaudible
movements that sometimes
accompanied them or palpable
indicators of the ways poems had
spoken to or even woken up
audience members.
Without realizing it, I had been
in the presence of a remarkable
response to the
power of poetry and it was an
unforgettable recalibration of
my own sense of what it means to
engage with poetry. One thing
that stays with me from that
evening is the fact that it
wasn't about
me performing well or hitting it
off with people in
these different places, rather
American conversations was about
giving people
space to engage with poems in
their own ways and in the terms
most meaningful for them.
If there's anything the
experience of this project had
onemade me want to
change about how I engage with
poetry and the other spaces I
move through, spaces like cities
and literary festivals and
college campuses, it is this. I
wish we could be more
consistently
willing to let go of our own
need for certainty and for the
desire to demonstrate our claims
to authority.
I wish we could turn down the
volume on
our egos and get past our own
impulse to judge, rate
and assess, and impulse fueled,
I suspect by the
many consumer based interfaces
we have gotten used to engaging
with.
Forms that ensure us that are
instantaneous unfiltered deeply
biased and often unfounded
reactions are of enormous value.
I wish that we could more often
let go
of the need to be seen as
exceptional
and authoritative in our
reactions, the need to garner
responses that demonstrate our
exceptional and authoritative
status.
And simply submit to
experiencing powerful and
difficult to summarize feelings
together with others.
I wish that together in whatever
versions of community we
represent we would more often
allow ourselves to wander a wile
through the wilderness of
new feelings and the wilderness
of old feelings in new forms
without needing to know and
declare where we are and how we
got there.
In other words, I wish we could
muster a willingness to get lost
together.
, which is essentially the state
poems offer their readers and
the poets who write them.
Poems invite us to move on
pre-meditatedly in a question or
state of our people through a
series of spontaneous
observations and responses, some
of
which are conscious, others
unconscious. To something that
feels like revelation.
Poems draw us deliberately past
our certainties and our
assumptions and into
something startling and
consoling or chastening and
enlarging.
In order to most emphatically
experience poems we have to
surrender authority,  pay close
attention and let
the poem itself lead us to a
place where
a new kind of sense prevails. I
have long believed this was good
for the individual mind and
spirit.
Now more than ever I believe it
is good
for the collective, the
community, even something
resembling the nation.
During my travels I have
encountered
many regional poets laureate
working with energy and
generosity to strengthen their
communities with the things
poetry offers.
And so it is my great honor
together tonight with them for
conversation about the ongoing
work of poets laureate and
the ongoing work of poetry so
I'd like to welcome the poets to
the stage now.
[Applause]
>> Okay so hopefully we can kick
this off and we will get some
other
perspectives on what it has
meant, what it means to be
sharing and engaging with others
via poetry, starting from the
right side of the stage Vogue
Robinson is poet laureate of
Clark County Nevada.
[Applause]
>> She is a dynamic community
builder, a
galvanizing force in the Las
Vegas literary community. When I
visited, she was very clear to
tell me, it's not the strip.
That's not Vegas. Vegas is
people. Vegas is writers.
Vegas is neighbors, Vegas is
people who are building
something together. So she's a
booster for the cities and
counties cultural riches.
She hosts workshops, writers
gatherings and serves the
community with poetry programs
like the workshop she conducts
for people who are living with
Alzheimer's.
And next to her is Tina Chang
who is poet laureate of Brooklyn
New York.
[Applause]
>> Tina and I grew up together.
We were classmates as graduate
students back when we were just
dreaming of maybe
making a life together as poets,
so it's
a really so very beautiful to be
here direct together and
celebrate the work that she has
been doing in her capacity. One
of the major emphases of her
time, and she's been poet
laureate of Brooklyn
for 10 years, has been children.
She's created a program to bring
authors in the public schools,
and she's
also led workshops with all age
groups, from elementary school
kids to adults and
retirement centers and
facilities.
Her laureateship has been going
on for 10 years like I said and
throughout the time she's found
powerful ways to celebrate and
promote poetry as a life-saving
tool.
[Applause]
>> Next to her is Kealoha, who
is poet laureate of Hawaii.
[Applause]
>> I have mind and envy.
Kealoha holds a degree of
nuclear engineering from MIT and
one of the things he has
used the laureateship to do is
expand the vocabulary and
methodology that we associate
with poetry.
He has epic performance poems
that like
the story of everything, right?
That explore the universe from
the Big
Bang to the present, or native
culture and different debates
about what that means, or
feminism.
And he uses discourse from
science, storytelling and social
justice to create these really
dynamic pieces.
[Applause]
>> Next to Kealoha is Jeanetta
Calhoun
Mich who is poet laureate of
Oklahoma
her work in the world celebrates
Oklahoma history literature and
culture and has led her to
communities and schools
throughout the state, she spends
a lot of time in rural
communities as well so I'm
excited to hear how our
experiences match up with one
another.
She's also taken it as her
mission to encourage Oklahomans
to write their
states history and explore their
own stories via poetry.
[Applause]
>>
And Adrian Matejka is poet
laureate of Indiana.
[Applause]
>> In this role, he has
tirelessly
traveled back and forth across
his state, hosting workshops and
readings with visiting writers,
and I have traveled a lot, but
when I visited Indiana twice,
and when I catch wind of what
Adrian is doing, it's really
tireless.
Like I am deeply humbled by the
generosity and dedication.
He's also building an archive of
poets with ties to the state of
Indiana, which is far-reaching.
And we visited
a small library in Franklin
Indiana, a school in
Shelbyville, and there's a
really beautiful sense of
stewardship
that he brings to the world. So
welcome, Adrian.
[Applause]
>> And we will be led in
conversation by
Jennifer Benka who is president
and Executive Director of the
Academy of American poets
[Applause]
>>...
and as you heard, she is a
powerful
advocate for Po poets, poetry
and poetry organizations
nationwide.
[Applause]
>> Well I want to start my
first, Tracy, thanking you again
on behalf of all of
us for your brilliant brilliant
work serving our nation is poet
laureate.
[Applause]
>> I know very clearly that you
have
touched the lives of so many
people on your visits.
I also want you to know that you
have influenced the work of
poetry organizations across the
country.
One of the things that I'm lucky
enough
to be able to do is work in
partnership with 25 poetry
organizations across the US who
are
collaborating and have formed an
alliance called the poetry
coalition and because of you and
the work that you have done we
have begun a conversation
about how we are serving rural
communities in our poetry
programming and that is not
something we have talked about
before. So I want to thank you
for that.
[Applause]
>> You have been a model and
been such a
reminder in your work of how
poetry can be a commons and it
can also be common ground.
Your work reminds me of another
poet
who championed poetry's social
possibilities, Muro Rukeyser who
writes in her very influential
collection of essays the life of
poetry
a number of relevant things, but
one about how civilizations, in
order to survive, draw on all
sources of
knowledge. Any source of
knowledge that they can find,
history, inventions, science,
and
yet somehow throughout the ages,
poetry
sometimes has not been used as
much as maybe it could have
been.
And yet, she says that when
communication seems to break
down, it is then that we need to
tap the roots of communication
and that is where poetry dwells.
Because it is an poetry that one
source is speaking to another
source.
And that's where, and how
personal and maybe communal
transformation can be sparked.
And perhaps that's why there are
in
addition to the national poet
laureate
position, a growing number of
states and cities who have
created poets laureate
positions.
The first state that had a poet
laureate was Colorado in 1919.
And over the decades a number of
states have created that
position. Now we have 45 states
across the country that have
poets laureate.
And interestingly, now we have
many many cities that also do.
And also US territories and
tribal nations and that is
something that my organization
has been following.
And watching and tracking. The
first city I believe that had a
local laureate position was
Mattis Madison Wisconsin for
1977, for the badgers in the
audience. There you go that was
for you, Mr. Casper.
But most of the poets laureate
positions that have launched on
the city level have been since
2000 and 2001. Interesting,
right?
There's a part of me that
wonders if there's a connection
between what happened on 9/11
and the need that
cities have to understand those
tragic
events and find important and
meaningful
ways to have conversations that
can help heal and move forward.
So I'd like to start there.
The important civic role of the
laureate. Why does it matter
that states have poets laureate
positions and that cities do.
What is it in your role that
you're able to do in terms of
sparking dialogue. I'm looking
at you, Adrian.
>> Okay well the great state of
Indiana, the 19th state in the
union has a very long history of
poets laureate.
We've had a 72 years of poets
laureate, but I'm only the
second one who was not white.
So the case at least in my
laureateship one of the civic
duties is to do some of
the work that I think the woman
from Kentucky was talking about,
like getting a conversation
going
that is not from the same
perspective of those who've they
have been speaking with. This
has nothing to do with a really
wonderful poets who have been
doing the
work before I got there. They
all care deeply about the state
of
Indiana. The state of Indiana is
a very diverse state. It's a
very problematic state in a lot
of ways racially and
economically.
So it is at least in my
experience it
has given me an opportunity to
expand the conversation just a
little bit, to show them that in
fact there are a lot of
different stories that need to
be
told, not just the ones that had
been going on the last 17 years.
>> I was thinking about the
question because you sent it to
us earlier, and
for me, poetry functions on the
boundary between the private and
the public.
It functions when I'm writing it
because I'm engaging with other
things and I think it also
functions that way for people
when they hear it, and I'm not
sure...
some kinds of ritual used to do
that and we don't have a lot of
ritual left in our communities
anymore.
And I think that two-way street
between
your internal self and your
Celtic se civic self that is
activated in poetry
is where the magic happens and
for me I want to share that with
everyone. Poetry saved my life
in many ways.
I want to take that, and also I
want to
make sure that the rural areas
where
actually they are more diverse
in Oklahoma, the
rural areas are more diverse in
then that cities, Native
Americans, African Americans,
Vietnamese, all kinds
of people, much more than people
think, and I want to make a way
for them to enter the civic
conversation through the poetry
that I help them right in
workshop.
>> In my experience, in my
brain, the way that I see all
the different things we do with
all our outreach and the way we
approach our poetry, it's really
what it bubbles
down to is making poetry
accessible every day for people.
And that not something that is
intangible but something they
can interface with.
And it is there for them and it
is present and our job is to
bring not only our work out and
share that, but also to bring up
other people throughout our
communities and make their work
visible as well. So I think when
we combine those things
then we start to have a dialogue
between different folks from
different communities and
pockets and that way we can
further along as a society.
>> I have so many thoughts based
on what everyone is saying. Just
to go back, I'm the port
laureate
a of Brooklyn and Brooklyn is so
already so rich in history and
culture. Poetry is a pretty easy
sell where I come from because
everybody who wants to
be a poet or who has a very rich
artistic life seems to find
themselves there, oftentimes I
wonder why.
Of course it's physically
beautiful but also just a kind
of go back to something Adrian
was saying about the history of
poets laureate in Brooklyn,
there were three poets laureate
before me and they
were all male, so I was the
first woman and also the first
person of color.
So with that comes great
responsibility, I think. I often
ask myself, because Rob Casper
and a few others that were on
that poetry committee who I was
really lucky enough that they
reached out to me to apply for
this position, I often ask
myself as I'm sure some of the
other poets laureate have asked
themselves too, is why me?
And when I think back on it I
think about the role of how
important it is to
be a person of color and how I
want to
address not only diversity, and
I think we can all speak to
this, but also diversity is so
different from integration.
New York, specifically Brooklyn
is known as a very diverse place
. Often that is the first word
that comes to mind when people
speak of Brooklyn. And I think
in the various communities
that I have just been honored to
just be
welcomed into, I think that one
of the
greater challenges that I feel
is how do we find, within the US
overall true integration, and
does that truly exist?
And I think poetry is really one
of
those very rare spaces, and
maybe it goes back to some
of the things that Tracy was
mentioning in many of her
beautiful stories, it has so
much to do with vulnerability.
We are each of us so very
vulnerable at the core and I
think many of us walk around
trying to keep it together,
trying to have an armor because
the armor protects us and helps
us to function. So I think in
the civic work that we all do,
it takes a great amount of time
and effort to be able to break
down
those walls and I find that
poetry has the capacity to do
that and I think that a lot of
it
has to do with the silences that
poetry just welcomes in. I think
in the state where we are right
now within the US, so much of it
is about how much noise we can
make and how much we can sort of
show what it is that we know.
But I think poetry kind of lays
out the space of how much we
don't know and how much beauty
there is and how much we
want to answer to all the
curiosities in
the world and I think that civic
engagement and that curiosity
have so much to do with each
other.
>> I think the role of Port
laureate,
I'm the second one to hold the
position and it's not state or
city but the entire county so
it's a very weird
position to hold as far as what
area are you in charge of, if
you will.
I think that it validates the
idea of following your passion.
When I go into classrooms and I
go speak with students the idea
of being a writer is a valid
thing. Especially when teaching,
if it is a
workshop in the community or in
the classroom it's also about
allowing people the space to
express their feelings and let
them know that their story is
valid.
And I think that Las Vegas as a
city is also building its
identity and wants to tell its
own stories.
Lots of people come in, write a
story based on one or two years
of living
there, the people who are born
and raised in the county or city
or area tell you how it is
developed, how this casino went
down and came up and got
rebuilt. How the street is still
under construction.
But the changes now where like a
lot of the legislation and the
people in power shifted and
there are a lot of women in
power right now in Nevada and
it's cool.
So I think the yearning to tell
your own story but also the
permission to
tell your city's story, your
county's story, your states
story and going forward with
that and I think that
encouragement that writing is
valid and that people still read
books.
[Laughter]
>> So, poets make excellent role
models. And all of you are
excellent role models.
And hopefully as we are all
appreciating more deeply, poetry
has this incredible capacity to
spark conversation that can help
strengthen communities.
Vogue, you were talking about
the importance of storytelling,
preserving stories.
What's interesting about the
role of
poets laureate is that it sort
of puts a poetic twist on
Shelley's notion that poets are
the
unacknowledged legislators of
the world by acknowledging that
fact. You know, right?
.>> by legislating.
[Laughter]
>> Were there civic themes that
you were interested in
addressing during your term?
Issues that you cared about in
addition
to diversity and representation?
Can you talk a little bit about
that and how you went about
addressing those issues?
>> Yeah, I mean one of the major
things I have been concerned
with is the ways in which
poetry is undervalued as a
teaching tool and as a
historical document and is an
opportunity for expression in
the ways we have been talking
about.
So I came into it with the
agenda that I wanted to try to
get in front of his many young
people as I could and in
front of as many people who
couldn't afford a workshop as I
could, as many people who never
thought that poetry was for them
as I could.
To allow them to sort of dictate
what poetry could be.
Of course in the great state of
Indiana I don't know if I'm
supposed to share this, but
whatever...
[Laughter]
>>...
it's a government position so I
had to sign a document that said
I wouldn't criticize the state
government.
And so I'm not....
[Laughter]
>>...
especially since the governor
went to my high school.
But you know there are some ways
in which it has actually been in
all seriousness very useful to
me, the state organizations have
been a great help in trying to
get to some of the communities
that I don't have the
wherewithal to get to.
So I don't know if that is
exactly what you're asking but
that is what  my plan was.
>> I meant to say a while ago,
Oklahoma
was the fifth state to have a
poet laureate. Violet McDougall
was named poet laureate in 1923
so I need to recognize her.
Many of you may have seen the
huge coverage last year of the
school teacher
strikes in Oklahoma and one of
the things that came out of that
is that their union sold them
out.
And there's still 25-year-old
Chuck's books. I went to a
school in Eve on Oklahoma where
you can look down the
floorboards through the
crumbling foundation and see
the dirt beneath the school and
that's where they were trying to
teach and work. And that was not
unusual. Ceilings falling down.
Flooded classrooms.
The teacher's had a good reason,
and they were not just striking
for pay.
The teachers list pay was on the
last even though we lost 30,000
teachers in the last five years
because they cannot make enough
to eat on, what
they wanted was to have decent
buildings and money  spent on
the children.
So I do a lot of work in
schools, but when I'm at the
schools I also, if I can get
time to have an in-service with
the teachers and even if there's
not time
for an in-service I leave them
handouts
or lists of resources like
teachers and writers
collaborative, in order to do
what I
could do to
support them in their great
mission
in educating a populace whose
parents don't really want them
to be educated or maybe the
state doesn't want them to be
educated. I didn't have to sign
anything.
[Laughter]
>>...
and so that's what I try to do
by working with schools is
actually leave
more for the teachers to help to
bring poetry.
>> I have to choose two because
throughout poetry we have to
address all kinds of issues, but
the two that I
think have bubbled up in the
recent years have been
particularly our science
literacy and our ability to
address climate change. So that
is something I've been really
focused on in my work, is laying
out the issue, defining and
laying out these solutions and
how we can move forward.
So I think that has been like a
serious
focal point and in addition to
that I
have also been focusing on
returning to source, going back
to the
indigenous stories of Hawaii and
one in particular that I just
wanted to highlight. There was
this creation chance that was
imposed in the 1800s, so I'm
sorry it was the 1700s, and what
it said
basically was at first was born
darkness
and then was born see slime
which is basically bacterial and
then there was
the coral ponds and starfish
as well as plans and then born
crustaceans and insects and then
the fish you know where it's
going, then were born the
reptiles and mammals and finally
humans so it's basically
evolution theory told in the
1700s through native Hawaiian
chant oral traditions.
, Just on the note of history,
Darwin's
origin of species was published
in the 1800 so we are talking
about roughly 100 years before
the Western world got a hold of
it.
So, but the cool thing is when I
go
into the schools or into these
auditoriums and I tell that
story, we
begin to realize that native
cultures have very significant
stories to tell and they are
very much on point with science
and mental, logical capacities.
And so it is the celebration of
all
different kinds of stories that
have
allowed, has been another focus
I guess in my work.
>> So I became a mother for the
first
time at right around the time I
became
poet laureate, and so I think
that those two worlds really,
they had to speak to each other.
For example, the night that I
was
inducted as the poet laureate of
Brooklyn I was actually carrying
my baby in a baby Bjorn.
So when I looked at, I still had
another child but when I looked
at my children I really wanted
the role that I was fulfilling
as a poet laureate to
speak to not just them, but all
children.
Because when you are raising a
child you get to grow along with
them. You get to see the joy of
them forming and understanding
words for the first
time, and the joy that is. And
so I started to think about what
is
it that I could do for children
in many different communities
and one of the
things which kind of goes back
to something which was already
stated is
that I thought about teachers,
and I thought about their jobs
and how
often and how much they gave
over their
resources to try to provide
books, to try to provide
everything needed so that these
children could fortify their
language, fortify communication.
So I developed programs to be
able to bring authors into
schools. But not only that I
developed also
diversity funds, so that these
teachers don't have to spend
money out of their own pockets
to be able to get students books
that they felt that they needed
that would diversify what they
were reading.
And those authors also tried to
diversify as well.
There is one author called Kelly
Starling Lyons who also is a
founding member of the Brown
bookshelf, which really promotes
the work of African-American
writers and
African-American stories, and
she had this wonderful story
which she shared with the
children that when she was eight
years old she read a book for
the first time called roll of
thunder hear
my cry and she said, it was the
first
time that she saw an
African-American
child on the cover of a book and
it convinced her that she too
could be an author. And so I
think just hearing those
stories in many communities I
think helps to really promote
this idea that these children
can live this kind of life, that
it is not outside of their
reach.
So I think in the work that I do
I'm also thinking about the
children and providing books for
them as well, and a
lot of that has to do, as
everyone knows here, has to do
with fundraising. So much of the
arts now, as it always did, I
think suffers from not having
enough funding.
So a large part of the work that
I do, and which I think actually
that you have addressed at the
Academy of American
poets is really trying to find
funding
in all corners and talking to
people and I think that we
haven't really gotten to that
yet, but that's also a
large part of our job, is not
being only a speaker for an
toward the community but also
how are we going to
realistically envision a project
and put it into actual being and
push it forth into the world.
>> To piggyback off of that, a
lot of my internal missions
were finish Bruce's work, which
is the previous poet laureate of
Clark County, finish what Bruce
started, one of them is bringing
the California schools program
to Nevada in it was how are we
going to get the
funding for this where we are
making it so that poets can
live, can have a
sustainable lifestyle in which
they are going to classrooms,
teaching poetry, being paid for
their time and the lesson plans
they are creating and also
living their lives and writing
books as well. And so it was the
one thing that Bruce
didn't fully finish but all the
proposals were there and I was
like I'm
going to take in and figure out
where to submit it and get
funding for this particular
program.
And I thought about the proverb
of lifting [inaudible] climb
that I'm able to go in different
places as a result of the
position, this title, people
either know what it is or they
cannot pronounce the word. One
of the other.
So the places where they know
what it is then more doors open
for me.
Cool, you let me in. If you want
me to speak at this I think we
should also bring this poet.
Can we bring another poet in
who's going to do this and it's
going to be
this much, and being unafraid to
request funds and being unafraid
to say no, this person spent
time prepping before, during and
after, we are having meetings
and discussing how these lessons
will play out.
And I thought about my
grandmother and
my grandmother at the time was
living in California still and
we cannot convince her to move.
And I was like well I need to
get my grandma fix. So I'm going
to take poetry into nursing
homes. And I found a project
that was founded
by Gary Gleason, Glassner,
so Gary already had a program in
place
funded by the NEA that brought
poetry into nursing homes and
retirement homes, and they had
research there about
nonverbal communication, about
how sometimes people aren't able
to speak but they are still able
to listen, about how a person
can hear a poem that
they had to remember if they
don't remember the street they
grew up on or their
daughter's name or a poem of
their daughters if they hear it
will come back and that moment
you know, is a
priceless moment and my poetry
staff, that's really I don't
know, like the
building of community and
creating this
close-knit community where we
are all cheering for each other
I can name you 10 authors in the
past two years who have
published books in my community.
That had the guts to go forward
and
said okay I'm going to put a
book out but everyone was
editing everyone else. Did you
read Rodney's book, did you read
the first book, did you see
Angela's cover. What? everyone
was cheering for each other and
these poets came into my home
and
read poets to my grandmother and
my
grandmother moved into a home
and she made one of my friends
read his poem again. She said it
was too short, read it again.
And it was after a really rough
day and she came back, she was
back that day.
So that integration of family,
community and working artists
creating something more for
ourselves and connecting.
>> I just wanted to follow up on
something that Vogue said, first
of all
that is so great what you were
saying but I was thinking about
this idea of creating access,
right?
Like the way that one of the
opportunities that we are given
is
to open up doors around us I was
talking about these various
organizations that are kind
enough to
support me, and they don't know
the performance community in
Indianapolis necessarily but
they do now.
They don't know of these various
different community groups that
are doing writing at the library
on Tuesdays but they are
starting to learn about them
now. So one of the things that
we are able
to do as we get wired in this to
bring everybody, rising tides.
I'm so glad that you mentioned
that.
>> I want to underscore
something Tina, you said, but
also first
appreciate what we are hearing
about
poets in civic positions making
a difference in the
lives of teachers, making a
difference in the
lives of seniors who are in
institutional settings, making a
difference in the lives of
people trying to understand
environmental devastation.
The work that laureates are
doing, poets laureate are doing
on the state and local level is
largely unfunded. I'm just
curious.
How many of you have a stipend
supporting the work that you are
doing?
And I'm guessing Tracy not
included that it is around five
to $10,000. No?
>> It's 250 per month.
>> It is now 2500...
2500 is your personal stipend
and 7500 is for programming.
>> Most of the positions across
the US don't have an honorarium
attached, as you have seen, and
if they do it is externally
modest.
Nonetheless again as you are
hearing folks are traveling
around the state. They are doing
outreach. They are buying books,
they are supporting teachers.
Just a public service
announcement...
[Laughter]
>> These positions are run
through the
governor's office, the mayor's
office, the state humanities
Council.
I encourage you to reach out,
find out who is running the
poets laureate
positions near you where your
family members might live, get
involved, support them. They
need it. But now to some good
news.
I'm sure, and I hope that you
may have heard that poetry is
booming.
I think we have some friends
from the national endowment for
the arts in the house
[Applause]
>> There they are.
>> I know in the work that I do
that in the past five years the
interest in poetry has been
growing year over year. We run a
website poets.
org and have a daily poetry
series and a day that Tracy is
curating this month for us.
Double digit growth year after
year.
And yet, we would still see
these bleak headlines about
poetry. No one cares. Poetry is
dead.
And we are thinking... not from
what we can see.
Well, thanks to the national
endowment for the arts, no one
has to believe me.
We actually have a study, and
arts participation study that
was released in
the fall that demonstrated in
the past five years poetry
readership in the US has
doubled. Doubled.
[Applause]
>> And what's very exciting
about this is that the largest
growth is with young people,
particularly young people of
color, and I should note, the
growth in
readership is the same in urban
and rural communities. Can I be
fact checked on that. Jessica?
Yeah.
So to Tracy's point, when people
are asking questions, well do
people really read poetry?
People are reading poetry
everywhere.
I wonder in your roles, if you
are feeling the swell of
excitement,
and if you feel like your work
has contributed to this over the
past couple years?
>> Yeah, what's funny about that
question that poetry is still
working or still alive, they
never ask poets that.
It's sort of thrown out to
somebody else kind of thing.
One thing that I actually think
is true and in Indiana certainly
I would love to take credit for
the work that is happening but
it's already happening when I
get there.
There are already people waiting
to
write poems, already people
interested in reading poems and
have just been creating
spaces to help them do that. You
know how quickly somebody will
snatch the mic when they have
something they want to say. It's
like the under 30 crowd or
something. They found poetry and
they have invested in it in this
really beautiful way. So like I
said, I will take all the
credit I can get but it was
sitting there in Franklin
already. It was in Bloomington
already. It was in Indianapolis
already waiting for an outlet.
>> I have to say the Oklahoma
poetry community has been strong
since about 1972.
And that's not just in the urban
areas. There's always writers
groups, there
are five or six monthly open
mics with
featured readers in Tulsa,
Oklahoma City, Shawnee, Lawton,
all around the state and we all
know each other. We are family.
Tracy just attended our family
reunion at the creative writing
conference in Oklahoma.
And so I had that to build from.
But I have seen something
different, is I don't have to
start by convincing people they
don't have to be afraid of
poetry anymore. That used to be
the opening part of my thing.
Well I can't...
they would show up for some
reason, they are curious but my
whole thing is you don't have to
be afraid of poetry. So I think
it is being taught better.
But I'm also going to give a
huge amount of props to
librarians.
I think a lot of the comeback of
poetry is from librarians and I
wouldn't even be a poet if I
hadn't fallen in love with a
librarian.
I see them
they are not just putting out
fiction anymore, they put it out
front, they put kids poetry out
front and hand it out. So thank
you librarians, all of you.
[Applause]
>> I absolutely feel the same
energy.
And for a number, all these
different
programs out there whether it is
poetry out loud, whether it is
the slam poetry
scene
, whether it's poets in the
schools, artists in the schools
and teachers
taking it into their own hands
when they know that there are
like standards they have to
adhere to, did I miss any
programs okay...
teachers taking it into their
own
hands, when poetry isn't really
like a standard that is
highlighted in what they have to
teach they go ahead and take the
opportunity, they really take it
upon themselves to teach this
stuff and when we get brought
into the schools it's like an
extra special thing for the kids
because they
have been already immersed in it
and we can take them even
deeper. So I have noticed just
the spirit of
poetry is very much alive and we
are
very much a part of it and like
you were saying though, we are
just writing the wave.
I mean, the energy is already
there and it's breaking, where
do you want to be on the wave.
You want to carve it up, do you
want to
be in front or on the back in
the barrel, what pose are you
making, so for me it's like I do
this poetry show every month,
it's like a poetry slam and I
rarely perform at it. Maybe like
three times out of the year.
And everybody always asks me how
come you don't really perform
all that much and I'm like did
you see the sign-up sheet? there
isfor me.
I want other people to get the
chance to be at the mic because
it's about them. It's about the
voices of our community and
highlighting that.
And so that is how strong the
scene is of poetry.
Don't listen to those other
folks who are saying poetry is
dead. You know.
>> Yeah, I mean I completely
agree.
I feel if anybody hasn't been to
the Apollo theater yet in
Harlem, you really
have to go because I think the
ways in which I grew up
with poetry
as like a typical sort of
studious person you know,
pouring over
my books, writing it in a
notebook and I think when I
started becoming very active in
this role I was invited to so
many different spaces so when I
went to the Apollo theater ISA
poetry lifted up in a way I
haven't seen before even
sometimes in the most
established situations where
established poets were appearing
we would see like 50 or 60 and
consider it packed. When I went
to the Apollo theater there
were hundreds of people and
everybody was dancing. This was
before the show started.
Everybody was dancing in the
aisles and everybody was in
these choreographed dances and I
had never seen that before, and
then since that time I have seen
more and more working with
organizations such as urban Word
NYC and the community word
project. There are so many
organizations that when I go
back to your question was how
much of it really has to do with
the poet laureate and their
role, so much of
it, as everybody seems to be
saying it all kind of  existed
before I was there.
I'm really just witnessing all
of it and absorbing it and
hoping to take that kind of
energy and bring it somewhere as
they are sharing their story.
But I go back to this, I don't
know why this s
story has stuck with me I went
to visit China a while back on a
literary trip to
visit different communities in
China and we were talking about
memorization and reciting poems
and one person said every
Chinese person really has a poem
in their head.
And I wouldn't say that that, I
would not say that was the case
wherever I traveled but she felt
that in China that it was the
case.
And I said why do you think, why
do you think that is the case?
Is it because in any place where
we experience hardship really
one of the only things that we
have to keep us going is the
written word? Is the word?
That is the thing even beyond
money and resources we have that
one thing.
So I think about that now in
terms of the
question, why is there a surge,
especially in the last few years
we are experiencing a
particularly
challenging time in our history,
and eyewitness, and I work with
so many
young people who feel no shame.
No holds barred. Just want to
express themselves now. They
feel that it's the time and they
feel really emboldened to be
able to push back and be able to
open up about what they are
feeling right now and I think it
has everything to do with the
moment we are living in now.
>> There's also the magic of
social media.
So you know, right now if you
walk into
a Barnes and Noble Ruby is on
the end.
You have to walk past her to get
her books. And I had students
who are like you
know who Ruby core is and I was
like what are you talking about.
This is a couple years ago.
So my students put me onto these
writers who had major
followings, who were extremely
secretive.
I still have not seen a picture
of [inaudible] Heed.
I want to know what she looks
like. I want her to have a
Wikipedia page that has more
information on it.
But she exists. So these small
bites, these micro poems are
saying what people need for the
quick moment and
the fact that these baby commute
computers that we walk around
all day in our pockets and your
scrolling through but at a
certain moment you catch a line
that speaks to you.
And I think actually it's
technically make people do close
reading because if you only have
this line that is the only
line you can look at
and you're like yeah, this is
deep, okay why I'm going to send
this to, you show it to your
friend, but it's one line. The
poem is probably longer. But you
know, you got that one line.
So I think about that and that
the world of publishing has
changed, soapself-publishing has
become a more respected thing.
The audiobook.
I have friends who are recording
books right now like you want to
read one of my poems and I'm
like yeah I will read a poem for
your audiobook. Cool. But we can
do with our phones.
Or you can buy materials, like
poetry has already been a really
accessible artform.
Pen and paper. It's not the same
way as painting or other things
like I scribbled my poem that
I'm going to read tonight on my
paper because my phone was
dying. Because of poetry. And
it's always there.
And it's in the dialect and the
conversations we had and the
metaphors we use every day. Your
grandma's language, your great
grandma's language and Oklahoma,
even
the simple phrases of longtailed
cat over a rocking chair.
These are all images that live
in so I think, yeah, publishing
has changed, accessibility, the
magic of social media and poems
are everywhere. Everywhere.
It's so great.
>> Before we close out, we'd
love for each of you to  share a
poem if you would.
[Applause]
>> Whatever you feel like.
>> All right, so I'm not going
to share one of my poems.
I want to share a poem by an
Indiana poet named Etheridge
Knight that I think is really
important.
And if you don't know, Mr.
Knight, I brought his book, one
of his
books so you could get a prop,
it's called haiku.
And there are nine of them but
I'm not going to read the
numbers.
Haiku. Eastern guard tower
glints in sunset, convex rest
like lizards on rocks.
The piano man is stingy at 3 AM,
his songs drop like plum.
Morning sun slants sell.
Drunks stagger like cripple
flies on jailhouse floor.
To write a blues song is to
regiment riots and pluck gems
from Graves.
Hebert pecan trees slips a
pencil shadow down a moonlit
snow slope.
The falling snowflakes cannot
blunt the heart aches nor match
the steel stillness.
Under moon shadows a tall
boy/his knife
and slice Starbright ice.
In the August grass struck by
the last
rays of sun the cracked teacup
screams
. Making jazz swing in 17
syllables ain't no Square poets
job. Thank you.
[Applause]
>> I was a actually asked to
write a civic poem upon my
appointment as poet laureate.
That's what I brought to read.
You may need to know only one
thing.
There is a word in here, wewoka
from the Muscogee Creek language
from
my hometown and it means barking
water.
Directive, you birth me land of
arrow and home, your red wrought
fossilized deep in my bones.
Near a roll mailbox a young or
whatever
calls sweethearts kiss under
mistletoe,
a tire swing spins in a shadowed
Grove searching horizon for a
child long gone.
Down a trail on the Prairie worn
by
Buffalo glimpse of a gray fox at
the
bottom of a slope Hunter sets
his sights
on a white tail dough, venison's
better than poverty's half
loaf scissor tail things on a
branch of black willow, coyote
yips in the hills, a comical
robe.
Alone in sere pastor under skies
blue bowl crow call a code that
catches in my throat.
Under a flat Yellowstone up a
dusty red
road plant my ashes near Wewoka
on a dusty plateau
[Applause]
>> So this was inspired by the
movement
toward planting food in our
gardens and also the
sustainability movement.
>> We've been growing a garden
around our place.
We don't have much space but
we've been working the soil
beneath our feet watching the
green sprout over the
concrete watching the vines
rewrite the graffiti on the
walls.
And we know that this garden is
a simple symbol that there is so
much more to be done in this
world
and sometimes it gets
overwhelming but we're taking
responsibility for what we can
control and so we are starting
by planting seeds and
caretaking, making the ecosystem
thrive, watching the earth come
alive, reflecting on the way we
are living our daily lives.
See we've been growing a garden
overtime so when we step outside
we can visualize what green
energy looks like to remind
ourselves that we know different
from the trees.
That all the energy we need can
come from the sun, the wind, the
sea and the
infinite
warmth of geothermal heat. And
we know another world is
possible and no matter how
hopeless anyone of us
feels this movement is real that
our convictions lead to
legislation, lead to
conservation
that technology must serve
ecology and so this garden is
how we redefine the boundary
lines between us and the global
community. We have come to learn
that there's no separation that
every nation on this blue planet
is symbiotically fused that
everything we do affect some
part of you so we have been
inspired to limit our impact, to
leave our surroundings, sorry
about that, leave our
surroundings better off then
when we arrived. We have vowed
to reverse the destructive tide
before we die. See we've been
growing a garden for our
children, leaving a better world
for them to
live in, teaching them to care
take what they have been given.
Show them to take a stand for
sustainability how to find the
balance between progress and
preservation, guide the way to
self reliant revolution you see
this garden is for our children,
this garden is our pledge to
them.
[Applause]
>> So, this poem is also by
another
poet, named Eileen Mylesfor the
work that she does and I found
and I wanted to thank Jenna had
of time
this poem actually on the
Academy of American poets site
and ever since I found it it's
been on my desktop and I read it
every day. Notebook, 1981.
I was so willing to pull a page
out of
my notebook, a day, several
bright days
and live in them as if I was
only alive,
thirsty, timeless, young enough
to do this one more time, to
dare to have nothing so much to
lose and to feel that potential
dying of the self in the light
as the only thing
I thought that was spiritual
possible and because I had no
other way to call that mind, I
called it poetry,
but it was/and time and bread
and
friends frightened and free
enough to want to have another
day that way, tear another page.
Thank you.
[Applause]
>>
It's how you get funding.
This poem is called when the
poem is done. When the poem is
done. Never. When you say so.
When a stranger calls it can.
When it's inspiration lives
behind its eyelids, under its
tongue.
When the poem is lifted by a
self-made
breeze becomes aspiration in a
room of your peers when it
illuminates you, midline, when
the poem is rooted in
itself, fruit bearing, Apple
Blossom filling the wind
beckoning hello and its leaves
all live as midday Boons
[Applause]
>> So thinking about the notion
of how we might choose to get
lost together and
thi listening to us I realized
maybe I will rephrase that. We
are lost.
We are lost and I think poetry
is a way of
acknowledging that and working
together. So this is a poem I
think that comes out of that
realization. An old story.
We were made to understand it
would be terrible.
Every small want
, every niggling urge, every
hate,
swollen to a kind of epic wind,
livid, the land and ravaged like
a rageful
dream, the worst in us having
taken over
and broken the rest utterly down
along age pastsed, when at last
we know
how little would survive us, how
little we had mended or built
that
was not now lost
, something large and old awoke
and then our singing brought on
a different manner of weather.
Then animals long believed gone
crept
down from trees, we took new
stock of one another. We wept.
To be reminded of such color.
Thank you.
[Applause]
[Cheers and applause]
>> Well, thank you to all of our
poets laureate and of course to
Tracy and thank you to Jen
Benka.
I'm Rob Casper, the head of the
poetry center, and special
thanks to Vogue for doing my job
for me. You should fill out
those forms, those surveys, they
will help us out.
You can leave them on your
chairs, you can leave them on
the tables in the back.
Speaking of the back, as you
walk out to your left you can go
to the when a
pavilion, our poets laureate
will be signing books, so get
some books, have them sign them,
tell them how much you loved
them and loved tonight. We hope
to see you back here in
September when we have a 23rd
poet
laureate consultant and poetry.
If you want to find out about
that event and all the events
that we do to
celebrate poetry and literature
year-round at the
library around Washington DC and
around the country, visit our
website, www.LOC and around the
country, visit our website,
www.LOC.gov/poetry. Thank you
and good night.
[Applause]